good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy wednesday it is
home day so don't forget to hump someone
you love whether that is your partner
your dog
no judgment here no judgment it's a
beautiful hump day i
personally feel like this week is going
by slowly and then it should be thursday
that's how i feel
yeah it's definitely feeling like a
thursday vibe on a wednesday which is
really not great
no it's not great you never want that
for your week but
hum day is always a reason to celebrate
it is a little too hot to be out here
oh my god you guys the heat wave is
reaching astronomical levels
i do feel like it is causing people to
go like a little bit crazy people in the
street are just acting
nuts more so than the average you know
new york
street walker yeah wow street walker
didn't think it could get crazier walk
around the streets
yeah yeah thank you um it's so [ __ ]
hot i know
a lot of places are just like guys
we're gonna get through this we [ __ ]
better yeah but if we get through it
with a
stormy weekend i'll be annoyed yeah
because we have a long weekend ahead of
us everybody has a long weekend ahead of
them and that's always something to look
forward to and life is all about having
moments of things to look forward to
and now claudia and i finally have
something to look forward to because as
of like 11 o'clock last night we planned
our weekend
yeah i just want to say like we were
going back and forth for the last week
about like what to do which house to
choose should we stay at a hotel where
should we go
and it was honestly weighing really
heavy on me like when i woke up in the
morning it was the first thing i thought
about because i'm like i will not be
stuck in the city for july 4th like i
just won't but at the rate we were going
like we were going to be stuck in the
city for july 4th
so you were feeling brighter i was
feeling brighter it's also just like
such an expensive weekend but we got
such a good deal like i feel really good
about our decision
i feel really good and the boys will be
there do and brew
and i'm excited for the bonding they're
gonna share i think they're gonna swim
yeah
doggy paddle i think it's gonna be so
amazing for their
for their development so we hope you
guys have your plans
checked out and if you don't this is
your sign there's literally one more day
like
girl like get a shareholder do something
only people on earth who like didn't
have a plan
everyone like has their [ __ ] together
when it comes to july 4th
yeah i know and it's like we usually do
but we we're fine
i never do um we have a good show for
you guys today not gonna lie
like let's let's be up front you know
the stories
they're not very good they're not but
you know what we have gotten monday and
tuesday both two days with really good
stories like juiciness
coming out of the stories
and so today is slightly mindless just
like nothing crazy
but we do have deer toasters which
always makes the episodes so good and
we have um brony recap tv recap real
housewives of new york which is really
turning into
like not a very good show no no no not
good there's no drama
no not good at all where is the drama i
don't know someone throw a glass
i really was like really thinking about
how i could
end my tenure of watching the show
that's what i was thinking about while i
was watching it like how could i get
away with
no longer watching the show and it sucks
because like there are some franchises
when the episodes like aren't juicy or
anything like
i still enjoy but i just think this
group is kind of like a rundown
look with a lot of the women and i it's
100 time for a refresh
i've said this once i've said it again
they're getting to oc levels of sadness
like they really are
i don't think we need a whole refresh
but five cast members on any show is
just not enough
i don't know why they don't add more
people to the mix and then
see what happens from there like i feel
like beverly hills we have eight women
it's a lot yeah no but there's so much
there's so many dynamics happening
no it's better yeah so anyways we have
your
recap but if this was a sneak peek like
we weren't thrilled
yeah but um
i have nothing else to hear oh actually
that's not true yesterday was such a
busy day
meetings meetings meetings podcast
podcast podcasts meetings meetings
literally for me i did three podcasts
yesterday plus
a vlog right so i posted yesterday my
getting ready
hair and makeup tutorial how i get ready
every day for the show
obviously my hair is up today but i show
you how i blow it out every day
and i think people are really enjoying
it you know some
some good beauty content i think you
know when you watch a youtube tutorial
and it makes you like want to like
redo your whole routine and like try new
techniques and try new products
that's what i felt watching the video
what did you take away from it
well i was really interested in how you
do your eye shadow because i just didn't
know that you did that you know like you
smoke out your under eye for the toast
like that was just a crazy thing i
didn't know about you
very lightly i guess is that what it's
called smoking out yeah and you're also
like so self-conscious about your
eyebrows like you didn't stop touching
them and talking about them and like
girl
they're really not that bad like you
have to get over it so it's just like
it's always going to plague me like ever
since i was a youngin like
my eyebrows just are my cross to bear
and i feel like you were talking about
them a lot just like
people wouldn't comment on them like
you're aware because i've gotten so many
comments like they've
they've beat me down about my eyebrows
like now this is the result do you know
what i saw in that vlog
a broken woman like literally like you
were so [ __ ] self-conscious about
your eyebrows and i swear to god there
was literally nothing wrong with them i
was like she's like this one's so much
better than the other mic
they literally look the same that is so
funny well thank you for that and also
if you did feel like influence
to do anything that i do i linked every
single product like i went out there
i got the links and i shared them with
you so
i got i have some good products i think
that eyeshadow palette that i use i just
got and i just think the colors are
stunning tartlet
juicy palette because i saw a makeup
artist had it and she used it on me and
like the colors just really worked for
me and then i just
went out and got it for myself she was
actually going to give it to me which
was so
so nice i was just like i can't accept
no but i'll go get it for myself
speaking of patreon we have another
episode dropping today it's the fifth of
the month and it's kind of like the one
everyone's been waiting for you know it
is a sit-down interview
one year later with olivia ashrae aka
michaela's mom and we really got deep
into it
she teared up at one point and so did i
like it was really beautiful
everyone got their questions answered
about motherhood about going back to
work about michaela
about the podcast maternity live about
olivia choosing not to share pictures of
mikael on social media like
so much we really covered everything and
it was a really really really like a
honestly like emotional episode wow i am
so excited to listen to it
and then you have the pleasure of
listening to the redheads episode
see content content content meetings
meetings meetings podcast podcast
podcasts and also like with this long
weekend ahead of us like we didn't want
to leave you guys stranded
there is so much content to get you from
thursday to tuesday though i hope you
guys will be having so much fun that
like you know the content can wait till
the following week yeah so this is a
good time to tell you guys like we're
taking off friday monday
yeah because we were just feeling out
like what the corporate world was doing
and it seems as though like that's what
people are doing
yeah and we're really looking forward to
doing that as well we adhere to the
morgan stanley
like a holiday calendar so we really do
so i'm excited to listen to olivia on
the patreon redheads episode drops
tomorrow we recorded last night and it
is
flames truly the girls are just like
the girls are on one we gave them pizza
before we started recording i was gonna
ask you if you think everyone was on one
because usually you guys go to dinner
afterwards and i'm sure you're just like
hungry and kind of depleted
when you do the podcast but we ordered
two pies of pizza before the redheads
arrived and then everyone had like two
slices before
do you think that made a difference you
know i do but i don't want to say that
like
in any other episode we we are depleted
and hungry because like
once those mics turn on the girls turn
on like we're so
we're so passionate honestly like i
think actually
in last night's episode like the passion
is jumping through them it's
palpable it's palpable also because like
we're all talking about this book that
we all really like
and then we're just talking about books
that we like in general and
you can really feel the passion i swear
you know what book i really liked
girl wasn't a job the crazy beautiful
life of an instagram thirst monster a
new york times bestseller available
really anywhere audiobook ebook amazon
kindle barnes noble books a million
you get it in canada it's really like
people are kind of
still quaking over it so it's the book
of the summer reese witherspoon said so
check it out
check it out it's a great bee treat and
for your long weekend i couldn't
recommend a better book
and if you don't like reading there's
pictures in the middle
is this book upside down yes it is okay
if you don't like reading you can get
the book on
audible yes yes jackie make the sale
make things you can actually go to
audible.com redhead because we have a
promo code for you
um you do we work with audible yeah oh
so you can get a promo code on my book
on any audible no on my book sure sure
yeah it's it's vertical integration
get claudia's book on audible if you
don't like to read but go to audible.com
redheads oh didn't know we got a code
how legit are you guys working with
audible
no totally our sponsors for the episode
guys are actually like really great and
so
booky you love to see your passion
projects becoming like full-blown
empires you know
you really do no you really really do
that's how passionate i feel about the
redheads and
i you know i see the numbers i see how
many people listen to the toast i see
how many people listen to the red heads
and i'll say that there are some people
that don't listen to the redness
that listen to the toast and i just want
to implore you
you're missing out i agree you're
missing out and then also yesterday i
was on another tnn podcast that i'm
pretty sure drops today but just in case
it doesn't
i will get back to you get back no but
i'm pretty sure that does i just like
it does okay i'm on mood with lauren
elizabeth today we're talking all about
wellness like
the journey where i'm at now because i
was like so hard on wellness when i got
back and like
now i'm in a place where i'm i'm you
know um well
i'm well and i'm just maintaining
wellness and we had such a good
conversation i had so much fun talking
to her i hadn't been on mood since pre
pandemic so i really think like
if you were to listen to that episode
and then this episode she's a whole new
two different gals yeah i was just
talking about how like if you told me
two years ago like i was gonna go on a
wellness retreat and i was gonna be into
all of these things i was gonna have a
peloton bike in my house
i'd be like ish am i okay yeah am i okay
in two years
let's see like that's the thing like
we're constantly
growing we do it every day
we're growing
[Music]
such a good song and such a good message
100 kids
gross um we've got a great show i'm
ready to dive into
the i would say medium slow five stories
today
dragged out unnecessary oh my god
i'm kidding you know we always pulled
through for you guys but
just some days hit different than others
it's not our fault like nobody decided
to you know announce a pregnancy
like but even that's like that's not my
favorite kind of news to talk about it's
actually my least favorite what's there
to say congrats
like some stories are the saying even
though they might be super interesting
they're impossible to report on for more
than 90 seconds yeah like story so happy
for her
yeah it's like great stories that are
like pregnancy news like that like
sad news what is your favorite kind of
story i'm
so glad you asked i love a layered story
that's just that really sums you up as a
person because you are a layered person
no i like something that like you don't
really know about but i'm an expert in
like the frenemies drama
i love like explaining things to you
anything having to do with like internet
drama is like where i
thrive interesting and if anybody wants
to start any internet internet drama
with me
i'm so down just let me know where we
meet up and i'll start talking [ __ ]
about you on the podcast
mojo [ __ ] no i'm kidding i love you but
like if you want to start beef i'll do
it
okay cool cool i'm jeffree star boom no
i'm kidding okay
please don't come for me yeah you
couldn't handle it for one second i'd
like to literally cry in my room
yeah take a seat okay
well i guess what are your favorite
kinds of stories i don't know i'm trying
to think
i'm trying i honestly like i really like
the swez canal
like that oh i missed this that's my
favorite kind of story
suez news global being a part of
something
that is my favorite kind of news and
also like you know interesting like
we're learning stuff here news maybe
we're sharing with you we're giving
you something to talk about at the
dinner table on a date like that's
really my favorite kind of news
and you know what news i actually don't
like is when our opinions like are not
valued or like people like get
mad at us for our opinions like i
remember when we reported on
the call her daddy situation a lot of
people didn't agree with us and they
were like coming for us
it's like yeah girl it's not that
serious no and i also like this isn't a
type of story but i really do
like having um podcast news
no no no no that i always like yeah for
sure
and i don't want to say like an
unpopular opinion but i i really like
presenting all different sorts of
opinions well you are
literally like the queen of
unpopular opinions land like you
literally live there full-time
um and i don't know if you believe those
opinions or you just want to be
contrarian sometimes i don't know
i don't think i'm a contrarian type of
person i just really think it's
important to look at something from like
all different povs i agree especially
with like internet stuff everyone piles
onto one side and just like
takes aside because that's what they
heard not because like that's what they
believe right so that's just something
that's important to me
it's so important to do things that are
important to you so i support you 100
100 um and so i think like we've circled
the drain yeah let's go
we've avoided the stories as long as we
could
so without further a did it do where are
you
right here being perfect on hump day
ready to be hummed by his mum
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
oh my breath smells great great
i was gonna say my breath smells groot
because it's like
bruce yeah whatever today's episode is
brought to you by bruce
the best electric toothbrush on the
market for a very affordable price if
you haven't switched to electric like
girl welcome to the 20
21st century 21st yeah yeah thanks
welcome to the 21st century get yourself
an electric toothbrush and do not spend
over 200
because that's insane and you don't need
to thanks to bruce the brush comes with
six unique
modes to customize your brushing
experience the battery life on the brush
lasts four weeks it comes with a
magnetic charging stand and a compact
travel case
they also offer a subscription program
so you never forget to change your brush
head again
bruce will ship you new replacement
heads every six months so you're never
stuck using a worn down brush head
the design is very sleek brush's
electric toothbrush has a modern
aesthetically pleasing design and it
comes in trend driven seasonal colors
and it looks great on your bathroom
counter and it also just works great for
your teeth your gums you will love it
you can get 15 off your brush toothbrush
kit and the refill plan when you use
promo code toast at bruce.com
that's 15 off promo code toast
at bruush.com
love it thank you bruce first story tlc
officially cancels counting on drops the
duggar family after josh duggar's recent
arrest we actually spoke this week about
we were looking for a little duggar
update
i know but this is like the update that
i thought was literally 10 years old i
had no idea the duggars were still on tv
and honestly
shame on tlc because when the first josh
duggar incident happened like
years ago they made a whole statement
like we will not be working with the
tigers
they canceled 19 kids and counting okay
and then they gave them a show
called fine teen fits and fountain like
they just gave them a job
so they just like kind of swerved on us
and not that it's comparable but like
i'm still really upset
that honey boo boo got cancelled when
the reason they got canceled was because
the woman that mama june was i'm sorry
the man that mama june was dating sugar
bear
had like gotten arrested for something
[ __ ] gross
and they like didn't even give them
another chance but like the duggars got
another chance and it's like
bring back honey boo boo literally the
best show of all time sugar bear hair
care
i heard he was the inspiration for that
brand like he was all over the mood
board
yeah a hundred percent so tlc put out a
statement saying tlc will not be
producing
additional seasons of counting on tlc
feels it's important to give the duggar
family the opportunity
to address their situation privately
okay so first was 19 kids and counting
that got cancelled now it was counting
on and now they got it canceled so
what's next counting
like 20 plus yeah literally like or no
because they have to get rid of josh
like and his wife so it's like down to
17.
yay yeah so i'm just like this is really
shady of tlc because
the same exact thing they released a
statement the same exact thing happened
the first time it happened with josh
drugger
and that wasn't the end of the show so
they're just like shady little liars
yeah for sure you
dirty little liar fur shirt what movies
are from
i don't know but i what okay i'll do
some content okay thank you
you dirt i pop out of the sunroof of a
car
yeah thank you really good
trades you dirty little liar
so honestly um great this is like an
update in the case i heard that josh
duggar's like hearing got pushed back to
november
so he's just like chilling until then um
and i don't know i have no peace from
this story none whatsoever and tlc like
claiming to do the right thing after
they
really should have and could have done
it and pretended to do it 10 years ago
or however many years ago his first
incident was
i don't know this is the morally corrupt
tlc network and i don't stand for it 100
and also bring back honey boo boo that
is really the message here yeah i think
that's it
i think it was like her stepdad who was
acting inappropriate so just like take
him off the show yeah
the show's not even about him it's
literally about alana literally called
honey boo boo
was that what the show was called i
think so i think so that was
can we just talk for a minute about how
good of a show that was like
they literally used subtitles even
though everyone was speaking english
like it was the craziest [ __ ] show
like
true i don't even like i don't even know
it was just like family values
like they were just so disgusting like
they would have mayo eating contests and
like literally one of the
kids like had an extra toe like it was
just wild like
here comes honey boo boo that's what the
show is called i bet you it's on like
what's the tlc streaming platform
discovery plus
oh god right that sounds right it
actually doesn't sound right
it sounds actually it does sound right
that's like married at first sight and
everything
yeah yeah so i just think um i know
there's a small but mighty community of
us who watched that show and who loved
it and i do believe me and our sister
olivia like were the two biggest fans of
the show
and i was really devastated when it got
cancelled but apparently tlc has no
morals so they should just bring it back
yeah honeypoo has been in the news
recently too they have no scruples
uh about what i don't know i just feel
like she's been like doing interviews
and
good she's literally a star and like the
world refuses to recognize it just
because
they don't she doesn't fit the prototype
for what we think of a star but like
she's
literally gonna be the next
jojo siwa like she's a star and she was
the first and i've been saying this
for years she was the first yeah but
she's not as kid-friendly as josie was
she like curses and [ __ ]
yeah i'm just saying don't count out the
boo-boo
i [ __ ] love her okay next story uh
that's why raven's kyle massey has been
charged with
felony for immoral communication with a
teenage girl cory
cory in the house yup washington state
prosecutors accused him of communicating
with a minor for immoral purposes
according to a june 14 filing obtained
by e news
that's the that's a raven actor now 29
allegedly communicated with the young
girl during a two-month period between
december 1st 2018 and january 31st 2019.
the girl who e news has chosen not to
identify by name was 13 years old at the
time
and is now 16. like honestly
what is with everyone we've got drake
bell josh duggar kyle massey
jerry from cheer like everyone this is
hard [ __ ] is wrong with people
i have no idea texting a 13 year old
what are you doing you freak
massie allegedly believed she was a
minor when he electronically
communicated with her for immoral
purposes of a sexual nature quote
you know this is like becoming something
we frequently report on like i just want
to vomit like it's disgusting and i just
want to like add it to the list of
things that i don't enjoy reporting on
oh i'm so glad you said that a hundred
percent because it's really sick
it's so like how many different ways can
you say sick disgusting twisted
yeah and i guess the the theme between
all the people is like they're all
people who got famous when they were
like kids like drake bell kyle massey
um josh duggar not so much
jerry but well he's out the college yeah
it's just
it's so sick and i'm really like just
really over reporting on this so if
everyone could just like
start talking to people their own age i
would really appreciate that i think
that's a really good message
yeah just like you know stay in your
lane like play with people your own age
talk to people your own age
it's so twisted and i'm so sad because
i loved corey in the house yeah now like
that whole part of my childhood is
completely everyone like and i can never
re-watch that's a raven
without thinking yes so many parts of
childhood have been ruined 100
seventh heaven ruined
absolutely ruined what else oh the cosby
show ruined
ruined uh we could make a whole list
like
we really think hold on what was like
really the seventh heaven one was like
the big
the big one the big one yeah drop it in
the comments what's been ruined for you
yeah are you ready for our next story
sure a little um
age-appropriate news thank god yes sex
life co-stars sarah shahi and adam demos
are dating irl okay we need to talk
about sex life because i'm sure
like many of you i went home hit up put
up netflix
went to episode 3 minute 20 and saw a
big penis yesterday
big penis a very big penis and
i was glad that i was a part of that
moment you know culturally
culturally and then i saw the tick tock
that everyone was experiencing this and
i'm sure if you were just
like innocently watching this show on
netflix that penis is different
episode three minutes and i was prepared
you know
did you go back and watch some of the
show no i did not have the time like i
said three podcasts
meetings meetings meetings yesterday but
you made it a priority to go home and
just watch the penis of course because
like we said
research research we are all in on
research here sorry we're
so devoted to our jobs like it's not our
fault but i did feel like
now i want to watch more of this show i
would love to get your opinion on the
actual show because it's like so stupid
i know but i did find it really
interesting that these two people are
dating now
and i read like an article that she kind
of detailed how they met
you know we met the first day in the
makeup trailer and it was just over you
know
and it's like girl no like we know why
we know when it was over
just be real with us just about episode
three
minute 20. just be real with us woman
and woman like we know it's fine let's
not make it something it's not also what
i didn't realize because i i wasn't
looking at his face
[Laughter]
when he turned around was that he is the
actor from
unreal he plays like that the bachelor
the australian bachelor
and he's in your least favorite movie
falling in love
that um christina milian
in new zealand's netflix movie yeah yeah
is he the guy who fixes up the house or
is he like the villain
no i think he's the guy who fixes up the
house and then they fall in love with
him so yeah he's obviously like hitting
a stride recently in his work
yeah no and i think i think it's cool
like those
movies and shows are all very similar
that like hallmark lifetime vibe and
it's like if it ain't broke don't fix it
he's got a niche he does and i'm glad
he's also found one
can i say that like when i put out my
story yesterday like brand new episode
of the morning toast is up
i talk about the 15-inch penis i saw
yesterday i got
1000 messages from like my girlfriends
and my like gay friends being like
where's his penis i'm like episode three
minute 20. that is so funny i
so i posted on my story i'm sure you saw
like me i was crappy
going to the show but until you got to
the second story like you didn't realize
that i was going to something specific
so some one of my friends was like
telling me
oh my god i've been looking for a new
show should i start this yeah and then
tell her to start it episode three
minutes one immediately responded
oh okay
so so they're dating let's start dating
in real life also what i
did watch last night i watched the first
episode of too hot to handle oh what did
you think
i thought that everything that you said
was totally
on point who do you like who do you not
like um love melinda
i okay so as far as the guys they're so
like honestly all unremarkable like i
know and i just kind of always feel that
way even like when i watch love island
i i just feel like they are kind of i
can't remember everyone's name but i
really like the
the french guy oh martin he's
so cute and really a nice guy and i like
the stripper
cowboy i think he's englishman nathan no
no i don't think gregory no charles
david matthew yeah whatever the blonde
guy
he for some reason like just totally
overlooked
yeah and still is like literally it's so
sad like to me he's the hottest one
yeah and no one can give less of a [ __ ]
about it so funny like to hear like to
see everyone come down you obviously
form your own opinions of who you think
is the best looking and then when they
break off into groups and they talk
about who
everyone's interested in like i
personally thought the girl
who came in last kayla kayla i thought
she was like
so stunning and no one even mentioned
her jackie she
literally might as well not be on the
show it's the most shocking thing
because she's the prettiest one
that's crazy but then it also goes to
show you how much like yes all these
people are so hot to the point of like
you can't even compare them everyone's
hot
it's all about personality like that's
really like
it's really how you differentiate how
stunning is emily
emily is british like really into that
fuckboy cam
green bikini when she arrived do you
think i remember i thought the half-down
hair
still don't know british yes brunette
british
really tall really tan yeah yeah
stunning yeah
stunning everyone is stunning so you
have to like be have more to you than
that
100 which i always find interesting i
feel the same about love island it's
like the hottest person can come down
but like they don't connect with anyone
like you have to also have a personality
and they're boring and that's why i
think melinda is my favorite because
she's literally like maybe one of the
prettiest girls i've ever seen in my
life
but she's so funny she brought us a
little annoying which i relate to
because that is my personality
but she's bubbly and she's effervescent
and she's a great gal yeah she really is
so i'm excited to
keep watching that i'll miss jeff die
though i was looking forward to getting
to know him wasn't that funny
that was funny and wasn't it cool how
people now knew the show like
yeah oh my god weren't you at handle not
like what yeah i like that for sure
um are you ready for our next story no
that's not really a story just a set of
facts
no i'm not why because i'm feeling like
i
i want to be able to access a virtual
private network and i don't know how
please let people know how this is so
important i actually just saw a facebook
comment asking for our code once again
let them know today we're welcoming a
new sponsor to the show ipvanish
a virtual private network vpn for short
and a vpn is a super important tool that
helps you safely browse the internet
you can use a vpn on your computer
tablet phones even thing like
even things like your fire stick when
you're streaming media or trying to
access love island uk
when you're using a vpn all of your data
becomes encrypted so what you're reading
what you're searching what you're
watching
whatever it is that you're doing and
that's important because what you do on
the internet is no one else's business
but yours
if you want to go up to sex life and
watch episode 3 minute 20 as many times
as you want
that's on you and that's your business
um here's everything you get with
ipvanish just 3.49
for the first month or 31.49 for the
year anonymous ip addresses you can
circumvent any online censorships they
have more than 1500 servers
in over 70 locations so you can use a
vpn to watch new episodes live
of love island uk and you get 24 7
uh support emailing with them chatting
with them even calling with them and you
get protection when using public wi-fi
so go to ipvanish.com toast to claim
your 65
savings this is the time to sign up
because with our discount and their
current promotional offerings
you can get a vpn starting at just 3.49
per month or 31.49 per year
check out ipvanish.com toast to get that
deal and start protecting yourself
online thank you claudia okay give me
that set of facts you were
excited about okay cool the devil wears
prada is turning 15 years old so here
are eight facts you didn't know about
the movie until now can i guess
sure um anne hathaway had to audition
nine times for the role
the first one anne hathaway wasn't the
first choice for andy which we know
scarlett johansson was rachel mcadams
was i've heard that over the years
and we spoke about that like literally
last week so
but i think the other facts i personally
didn't know so i'm going to share with
you
first second one no designers wanted to
lend clothes to the movie
the iconic costume designer patricia
field was in charge of the film's
fashion but despite her status couture
houses hesitated to lend pieces
for fear of upsetting the powers that be
at vogue oh that's actually really
interesting isn't that an interesting
fact and you know what i was watching a
tick tock yesterday about a girl who
used to be anna wintour's assistant
and it was like five things i learned
here's how i got the job zana went
towards assistant
and do you know her name is anna winter
no that's what the girl said it's
literally winter like this season
i feel like she like did that on purpose
no so it's like spell it with an a
yeah no i feel like she was like meant
to be wintour and then she
liked how winter i'm just saying like
that that does make sense and also
i will i challenge anyone to show me a
movie that was designed
by patricia field that wasn't an iconic
classic right like if i
were you know an editor and they were
like patricia field is doing a movie do
you want to lend close i would be like
150
and like for when obviously the movie
about my life does
hit theaters patricia field will be the
costume designer you think so
100 okay she just really knows how to
like capture
in essence the moment yeah okay next one
in fact we didn't know but makes total
sense stanley tucci was the secret
weapon
the script was already pretty sharp but
tucci took things to the next level
often improvising moments for his
character that made the crap
made the cast crack up gertier loins as
miranda approaches was one of them
it was an improv yep courageous that's
so
interesting and he really is the best
part of the movie who would you say is
your favorite character in the movie
i really like okay i need to think about
it i do like i love stanley chuki
obviously
because also like when one you sit next
to him on a plane one time
and then you did not sit next to him on
the plane you watched that next to a
bald man and then you watch a movie like
it does hit different
no it does jackie okay you did not
you were in coach i think i was in the
car i was in economy plus
and i think i sat next to the guy from
kingsman
i do fine if we're being honest okay
yeah let's be honest because it's so
important but
there's nothing to say that it wasn't
stanley 2g no there's facts
i really had three witnesses me margaret
olivia i think it was merlin from the
kingsman i really do okay
i actually could see that yeah um
no okay so we can't decide who our
favorite is but i think we can all
decide who our least favorite is
three two one adrian grenier and he
actually did an interview recently about
how like
how we've all grown up with this movie
now 15 years later and we realized like
her boyfriend was so
not supportive and like kind of an
[ __ ] and she like bent over backwards
for him
and he did an interview and he was like
yeah no like you know what's his name
in the movie matt nate nate wow good
memory
nate was like really immature he hadn't
developed yet like they did this whole
interview like on how the character was
low-key like the [ __ ] worst yeah he
thought he made a grilled cheese so
all's forgiven
yeah that's like eight dollars of
doralsburg like okay well don't be
wasteful you eat it
she's watching her weight like don't be
a dick yes be supportive don't put
temptation
no like yeah i could literally write
like a dissertation on nate
100 so toxic but i do think if he had
been played by someone else he would
have come off better i
i do think that adrian grenier like and
i've i really have
i love entourage he has such an annoying
face i really like entourage i
hate vinnie chase hate hate hate hate
hate loathe entirely like literally
[ __ ] hate
the worst character on planet earth and
i'm obsessed with mark wahlberg and
vinnie chase is like loosely based off
of mark wahlberg not even loosely
and like it makes me think if i was ever
in a room with mark wahlberg like we
would not get along
no everything adrian touches
ruins hebrew and straws ruins look at me
here with my plastic straw tumbler
coming soon
are you ready for our next fact miranda
priestley's office was a dead ringer for
its inspiration
okay that makes sense he was able to
recreate the office so authentically
that the
designer was told anna redecorated hers
immediately after the movie came out
do you think that like that's her cross
to bear like that movie
well probably but i feel like
she comes off in the movie not bad
really like that's what you would expect
from the editor
of vogue she's like harsh but she's not
cruel and like i feel like miranda
because it is a movie like she has those
moments of humanity
do you think meryl streep has ever been
to the met gala or since that movie came
out
or do you think she's like banned
because that was a brave thing to do
to play anna winter so brave i don't
know if i could do it
um i'm googling right now like do any
pictures come up i've heard the met gala
meryl streep met gala she will attend
her first ever met gala next may and
that was in november of 2019.
so she never got to go so yeah she's
never been to a mecca
that's actually really interesting that
is really interesting wow
i guess and it doesn't seem like the
type of person who she does seem like
the type of person who holds grudges
yes but this next fact is that anna
wintour had a sense of humor about it
despite the biting parody of her
intimidating workplace persona the cast
and crew mem remembers her poking a
little fun at herself during the
premiere
she sat right in front of me and david
with her daughter and wore prada i
remember her daughter nudging her
through the screen like they got that
right
oh and years later meryl streep filmed a
video for vogue in
anna's office in which the two women
made a few subtle nods to their shared
history
oh okay okay so it's all good so it's
all good okay
so anna went to the premiere i didn't
know that yeah i didn't know that do you
think
and she wore prada oh because the devil
wears product
do you think that anna and lauren
weisberger the girl who wrote the book
are cool
[Music]
well if you read when life gives you
lululemons like emily who's
based on her no she's andy
no it's emily who wrote the book the
andy character
no emily wrote devil awares prada oh
that's a good question andy i think
yeah she's like a writer girl yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then she wrote a
different book from emily's perspective
where
emily is in good graces with anna anna
but lauren weisberger is the andy
character
yeah and there's no mention of andy
really when life gives you lou lemons is
a really good book
it is a really good book and i think
everyone should read it and not read
the one after the one after it she wrote
deborah's prada
then in emily pov after vogue and it was
really good called when life gives you
lily lemons
and then some random [ __ ] book that
just came out and it stinks yeah
sorry speaking of emily emily blunt says
comfort was key
the shoes had to be punishing and
keeping with the high fashion world of
vogue but which meant that blunt and
street were always excited for their
close-up any chance meryl and i had i
know we were in uggs
and most of the shots from the waist up
cool i love emily blunt
oh do you know the most best thing ever
i feel like a lot of people don't know
this
emily blunt has a sister
yes her sister is married to stanley
tucci
yes felicity blunt or whatever that's
such a fabulous little
hollywood what no i when i was sitting
next to stanley on the plate
[ __ ] off he was going on and on about
felicity sister-in-law
yeah his sister-in-law and her sister
yeah i know for sure
yeah so so i just feel like a lot of
people didn't know that do you think
they might have i did do you think they
met 15 years ago like on the set through
emily i actually
do think i think it could be possible
they did okay that should be a fact in
this fashion yeah this oh
the shoes we were uggs who [ __ ] cares
it's like this person had two good facts
about
the movie and then they had to put
together a listicle and they're like
what's the least
we could do eight facts totally i'm
gonna give you the last two which was
meryl streep went method for the role
and regretted it um she an attempt to
make herself more intimidating on screen
she removed herself from the cast's
interaction she says it was horrible i
was miserable in my trailer i can hear
them all
rocking and laughing i was so depressed
that's the last time i ever attempted a
method acting oh that's interesting that
is interesting and then the last fact is
that adrian grenier knows you think nate
is the villain
and what you just said i i was just as
immature as him at the time so i
couldn't see his shortcomings
but after taking time to reflect and
much deliberation online i can realize
the truth and that perspective
okay good i'm so glad we're all on the
same page yeah no i mean it's such a
good movie it's so iconic i love
like fun facts about movies me too you
know there weren't that many stories
and you know what devilware's prada is
one of those e-movies we love that i
actually can stand watching like
e has the rights like the license to
four movies
and devil wears prada is one of them and
when it's on i will never not watch it
yeah i agree and they really do use the
term love
loosely though i do love the devil wears
prada
and you know what my favorite scene is
obviously when she finally gets her
makeover and then she's like walking to
work and like the subway passes and
she's in a new outfit
she walks past a tree and there's a new
outfit oh yeah like that's always good
and like whenever i hear that song i
can't think of anything other than devil
wears prada
suddenly i suddenly see this is what i
want to be
suddenly i suddenly see
why the hell it means so much to me
suddenly
and by the way my whole life i thought
the guy christian who
like takes her to paris and like tries
to kiss her and she [ __ ] or whatever i
literally my whole life like you could
not tell me differently
thought that was billy bush we know we
know
okay and it's not no way but i could see
how you it is
how you thought that okay it is yeah i
was like wow good for that guy on access
hollywood
got a real job are you ready for our
fifth and final story
i am okay me too
good we're both ready i love being ready
[Laughter]
okay fifth and final story netflix
acknowledges
lazy viewers by allowing us to watch
partially downloaded content
offline so you know when you try and
download a show for your flight and
not the whole thing downloads and you're
like [ __ ] if only i started sooner and
wait until i was on airport wi-fi now if
something is partially downloaded
you will be able to watch it this is
great of course i just really need
um like there to be some sort of netflix
like airline partnership like jetblue
has amazon prime video so if you have
the prime video app and you connect to
the
jetblue wi-fi like you can watch
anything and it's the only airline that
has that with the streaming service and
it's so stupid like everyone should have
it it's the best thing ever
yeah i don't know i i
but i'm not girl watching stuff on
planes is like so
you miss so much yes but i just have to
say like this applies to me like i'm
that girl like i'm i'm hot spotting my
ipad to my phone while i'm boarding
to try and download so this is helpful
for sure for sure but it's not
it's not the end like where there's more
that can be done to help travelers
watch netflix maybe also like reducing
download time yeah things of that nature
figuring it out yeah 100 and also what's
with like if you download something
three times like you can't ever download
it again
yes [ __ ] says who yes on my ipad it's so
annoying like you've really downloaded
too many things today like what is this
parental controls
no no or like sometimes i download
something for a flight it expires i
don't watch it
um the next time i'll download it again
and then like it says you've exceeded
the downloads like i can't download it
again yeah
but why yeah who made up those rules
that's kind of
garbage agreed well maybe they'll hear
our cries
um well those are the past five stories
and you definitely did not need to know
them but i do hope you enjoyed your time
with us i think that you probably did
and the show's not even close to over
because we've got the tv recap segment
real housewives of new york was on last
night
um the ladies went to harlem sonia got
really drunk
ebony and ramona had an insane
conversation
but ended on weirdly good terms yeah and
we met bernie shaw who i actually
really appreciated her energy like when
she was talking to leah about how she
was literally diagnosed with cancer 13
years ago and was given four months to
live
and now she's 13 years in remission and
how she just has like this whole new
lease on life she's like i do whatever
the [ __ ] i want like i don't care what
anyone thinks about me i'm like
i live for your energy and is she friend
of or sh because she goes on the trip
she's salem yeah and salem's next week
yeah
oh so maybe she's like friend of maybe
they're listening to our cries and
bringing in more people
there's such a desperate need for new
people yeah
and i feel like she's an interesting gal
like i did enjoy her i enjoyed her a lot
i thought she was really funny and i'm
glad that she's going on the trip
because we need
like new energy new personalities yeah
everything um i really can't even
remember what else happened luanne had a
conversation with her daughter who's now
also
sober for a year and a half and i guess
i didn't even realize that luanne's dad
struggled with
alcoholism and it like definitely like
runs in her family yeah when she said
like he's the river that runs through my
life i was like
that's deep and so now victoria being
sober is like
i think really good for luanne i really
i just get the vibe from luanne for the
last couple seasons like she's sober on
the show and then she's not sober
but i don't think that's the case now i
hope so but
i i yeah i get that vibe too but i
really feel like now
she tried to you know do it surface
level and just like her appearances
and then she really had to learn on her
own in in her own way that like no she
needs to be sober permanently
yeah well i hope that she sticks with it
because like i do really feel like she's
at her best when she's sober
i agree i think she's really uh like she
doesn't contribute that much this season
you know because she's kind of like
always quiet and i feel like when the
other women are getting
are drinking she gets like more anxious
and like has to kind of remove herself
but she's you know she's lou that's why
she was so quiet in harlem and like
ebony i think
brought it up to leah i thought that
conversation between ebony and leah was
really interesting and i think like
leah is the only person who ebony uh
trusts her opinion i think and because
that dinner in harlem was like
fun but like kind of a bust like a lot
of the women were like were bored
and i think that ebony definitely has
this like huge like burden
to be the first black house wife and to
just like use her platform and like be
funny and
interesting entertaining and also
represent herself and like it's just a
lot and i think that like she's
definitely struggling with like the best
way to do that
yeah um and i thought leah actually gave
her really good advice like be yourself
like do what's important to you but like
also know how to like have fun with us
like
it's not it doesn't always have to be
heavy and i think that was good advice
and i think ebony was like definitely
struggling it must be like
a lot of pressure to like be the first
black housewife
also with a bunch of women who are like
not adept
on really what's going on in the world
like they do really live in their own
bubble so i think it's a lot of pressure
and i think
she was going you know like having a
hard time finding the right balance but
i think
she gets there oh for sure and i also
think that
overall like she's an awesome housewife
like i genuinely
really enjoy everything that she brings
to the show like her commentary
confessionals
her cavalier her brew was quaking
she's a really cute dog oh my god brew
was
so excited to see a fellow cav on the
show
and when she said at her election party
that like leah's dog misbehaving like
made her dog misbehave like that
actually is what happens like i 100
agree and support her that's going to be
this weekend yeah like brew is such a
bad influence
but he's so sweet no and bruce not as
bad as angel
no angel was on the table like biting
leah's nose
no and never would never no he just gets
excited in pieces pants like
things happen things happen he's young
but yes i agree i feel like there's so
much to ebony like we don't even know
yet like
and honestly i've been saying this for a
while like we need
elegant rich housewives and that's
literally what ebony is like her home
is so stunning it looks like a hotel
room yeah stunning so like
i think there's more to ebony i think
she feels a lot of pressure
in the position position that she's in
and rightfully so um
but when ramona when they were taking a
picture at the harlem party in ramona
was like
i don't like this we're just like white
and black it was like it was honestly so
awkward and justice
for ebony's friend natalie who like has
been now at two of these events with
these crazy [ __ ] women and you could
just see her face she's like what is
going on here
yeah no when they first said they
aired that and then it went right to
commercial like
i was like what did you just say i was
like did you really just say that
and then when they aired it again i
guess it was like well received by the
group
yes because i was like how is everyone
gonna receive this comment like it's
very awkward and uncomfortable
but everyone was cool everywhere it was
funny um also i just want to say one
more thing i actually think um
a cash trip even though they just got
back from the hamptons i think a cash
trip is exactly what they need
and somewhere that's like not someone's
home like maybe they're in a hotel or a
house where it's not like
it's a people like it's not ramona's
turf it's not anyone's just like we are
going on a trip we're going to have fun
you know i don't have to like
worry about doing things your way like
leah can say whatever she wants at the
salem hotel
i think that that's actually what they
need i did catch up because i was really
behind and i just have to say like the
way leah treated heather thompson in the
hamptons was so vile and disgusting
and i just we breezed right past it
because i think heather went on that
trip realized she does not want to be a
friend of it it's not worth it i think
she's done filming like literally for
the rest of the season
and i'm just annoyed because like leah
really owes her like a
very deep apology i saw a headline this
morning actually
page six that leah said like she might
have been a little hard on heather
especially because ebony like did
miscommunicate what heather said
yeah and i felt awkward for ebony
because she started the whole thing when
she
like misunderstood what heather had said
and regurgitated it in a different way
to leah
yeah i guess leah was on watch what
happens live and she said i was
definitely hard on her
um she was like uh
when she watched the show back she
didn't actually hear the word dumb so
she was like i was like oops
well i think that like she like really
ran leah off the show
as far as heather and that's as far as
what i know just from like reading
tablets and stuff like i don't think
heather makes her attorney i don't think
heather even goes to the is going to go
to the reunion
and i wouldn't either i wouldn't either
like so she's never going to get the
apology she
rightfully deserves i totally agree and
that's what's so confusing about leah
because
sometimes she is so on the money and
then
other times it's
lunacy yeah no and she was actually
really um in a good space on watchups
live last night she wore a free britney
shirt sony was literally the star of the
show if anybody knows where her earrings
are from like please i need them
um and i i really do get
enjoy her getting to like explain
herself but you're right like she's been
so out of control but she is going
through something her grandma did die
like while she was in the hamptons like
that [ __ ] sucks
yeah that really sucks and of course
like i'm glad that they mentioned maybe
she felt like she shouldn't have come
yeah but not that that would have made
any difference and also like this is
lee's job
and she has to work and so i'm sure she
would have just also felt anxiety and
that's why she said i'm watching
because everyone's been saying like
why'd you go to hampton she's like this
is an obligation like we are an ensemble
cast we're not that big like it is my
job yeah okay i appreciate that she said
that until
and she has a family of 40 people so
they couldn't because of cobit all be at
the grandma's house they had to rotate
anyway pertinent information
and so i want to be able to move on from
her behavior in that hampton swords head
there because i do think like she was
at her absolute worst um
and i do think that sometimes you know i
don't want to give anyone a pass but
like yeah no things happen
and you you're in a bad place and you're
in a bad place but that can't happen
without a major apology to heather
that i don't think the opportunity will
present itself because heather's done
with this group
yeah so moving forward like i do feel
like there's a foundation for good stuff
to happen but like
it there's just really been nothing
meaty or juicy or even remotely
interesting and i just like need things
to happen i feel like ramona and sonia
are bubbling up i feel like they're not
in a good place
i think that ebony and the new housewife
bird and child like i don't think they
get along that's just the vibe that i
got like
i need something i need yeah conflict
conflict drama yeah fighting sides
everyone's fighting takes a high throw
drink like something
i agree also i just want to say cause i
think i said on the show that i thought
the pageant was going to be like so
stupid and i have to say like i was
smiling from ear to ear i thought it was
hysterical i thought it was funny too i
didn't think leah deserved to win i
thought tony morgan 100 deserve to win
and i'm just i'm glad that lou told us
that like
it was on purpose and i just thought it
was actually like a really fun activity
and i was being a hater and
it was it was cute it was a cute idea
like that's what you had to do last year
like get [ __ ] creative with your
friends
yeah in a basement like yeah and that's
what they did you do what you got to do
um all right final segment of the show
is dear toasters our advice segment
where you can write into deertoasters
gmail.com
anytime and do do what you do write to
us tell us what you're going through
conflict at work conflict at home
conflict
in your bridal party we'll take care of
it teardrop this is brought to you by
hush blankets let's talk about the
quality of your sleep
the reality is over 160 million
americans struggle with sleep and hush
is here to help
they have a wide range of sleep
essentials for every sleeper whether
you're a hot sleeper or a cold sleeper
they have what you need to get the job
done hush blankets carries everything
from pillows and sheets to their
best-selling weighted blankets which
jackie and i both have
and they even have an iced weighted
blanket so if you are a warm sleeper you
get sweaty in your sleep you might think
that a weighted blanket's not for you
even though there are so many benefits
it reduces stress
anxiety um if you're hot you might not
want that but they have an iced one that
keeps you cool which is really like
stunning technology also they have a
100-night guarantee with all their
products so if you're not 100 sold you
can try it out for 100 nights
and return it with no hassle whatsoever
i have the
blue weighted blanket it's the throw
blanket it's stunning i've had it for
over a year it's an amazing condition
and it really does work like
the technology is there like it does
reduce stress it does reduce anxiety and
it really keeps you warm if you're cold
yeah i love it brew loves it it's
actually the perfect sponsor for deer
toasters because sometimes you need
advice and other times you just need a
weighted blanket
from day one hush has donated one in ten
adult blankets and one in five kids
blankets to those in need
so if you are looking to upgrade your
sleep head over to hushblankets.com
and use the code toast for 40 off your
next purchase it is valid on all of
their products so that's hush blankets
dot com
code toast for 40 off it is the biggest
discount they offer so make sure to
check them out
thank you for that claudia all right
first off i love you both the morning
toast has become the 45 minutes of my
nine to five every day and for that i
love you
here's my predicament the other day i
was telling my boyfriend that i was
feeling fat and insecure in a swimsuit
around his friends family etc
he responded by saying no you're just my
tubby bunny
i think she meant to say tubby bunny now
i would like to
qualify that he often speaks in a joking
voice and calls me nicknames when he's
trying to be cute
however he proceeded to poke my stomach
and call me tugly over and over again
while i managed to maintain my composure
in the moment i cried as soon as i got
home because he made me feel fat
normally i find this behavior cute but
this time it hurt my feelings and i
don't know how to address it without
damaging
damaging a fun dynamic in our
relationship how would you proceed
should i just rub it off as a joke or
chew him out
doesn't the adjective toughly make me
sound like a whale i appreciate you both
a desperate toaster
who fears swimsuit season what is tubby
i don't know like i thought she meant
tubby i don't know but she said tubby
twice three times i'm gonna look it up
hold on
okay and i definitely think that there's
um let me see what she said again can i
can i read that
no not that i just want to see what how
she phrased her question
should i rub it off as a joke or chew
him out there is so much in between
rubbing it off as a joke and
chewing him out and by the way urban
dictionary says tubby is an individual
who is not fat
but has an unsymmetrically shaped
stomach creating the illusion that they
are indeed a fat ass
this website is so disgusting like i
can't i can't that's
regardless it's really hurtful and i
think you just need to tell him
yeah it also depends what kind of
relationship you have because like if
you
are have the type of like conflict
resolution where like something upsets
you you bring it up and you resolve it
then you should do that i get that
there's like probably a little bit more
like you feel embarrassed
but you got to bring it up yeah no this
is your relationship this is your
boyfriend this is a crossroads and this
is a
this is a very good indicator how he
receives this if he respects your
feelings like if that
it you should move forward in a
relationship not saying that necessarily
you'll break up over this if you let him
know but like the way that he
responds to you telling him that
something hurts your feelings and like
can you please stop i think is really
important to know
so i would just like sit him down be
like i know you probably don't mean
anything by it
like you don't have to chew him out like
i know you probably don't get anything
by it
but it actually kind of hurts my
feelings and doesn't make me feel any
better about how i was already feeling
so if you could please
stop calling me that i would appreciate
it because if you guys do have this like
jokey kind of candor he might not know
that he crossed the line yeah so unless
you tell him
there's no way that he knows i feel like
i've been that person before i'm always
coming up with like nicknames and
all these different things and i
definitely i feel like someone has said
to me
please don't call me that like yeah
definitely and i don't think it's like
awkward or anything i think you just
have to set boundaries
and i also feel like the longer you let
it go the more ingrained it is and it's
harder to correct
yeah you know and it's just gonna eat
away at you so just get it out but don't
don't be mad at him because i don't
think he did it with bad intentions i
don't think so either
all right next up this is a long one
dear jackie and claudia let me start off
by saying your podcast is one of the
best parts of my day
youtube both you two both make me smile
and are just so great
dear dear toasters is also such premium
content and it's kind of bittersweet
that i'm now writing and asking for your
advice
anyways here's the situation my
boyfriend and i have been dating for
three years and started doing long
distance over the past year as we both
started university in different states
the other day i was on his laptop
watching youtube videos snooping
and i came across a recently visited web
page only fans
of course i couldn't ignore this and i
clicked the link the user login was
already signed in under a name
john mitz which is not the name of my
boyfriend and was subscribed
to six girls with only fans and had
ongoing messages with the accounts
i was originally shocked and disgusted
with this uncovering it felt so personal
because we have such a good sex
relationship even with the long distance
and it really hurt that he was seeking
some
this sort of thing from other girls i
was so furious and i left him a note on
his laptop
saying nice only fans account while he
was out of the house
since uncovering the account i called
him out and gave him a strong piece of
my mind
he was embarrassed and now feels
extremely guilty trying to make it up to
me in any possible way
he told me he only watches it when we
are in an argument but i still fear
i still feel humili humility humiliated
and my self-worth has taken a hit i
don't feel good enough for him now and
i'm questioning a lot of things he was
aware of
my insecurities and i can't believe he
would engage in this he's already
sometimes controlling over what i wear
and he can get jealous when i have guy
friends
the thing is i've never given a reason
to doubt my loyalty and i am not a girl
who puts herself out there
what's your take on the situation would
you continue to brush things under the
rug
i'm looking for a non-biased opinion and
would greatly appreciate any insight
signed a very bitter and confused
toaster my unbiased opinion is this guy
[ __ ]
sucks this is so layered because first
of it was just the only fans thing i
think this is like a very
real issue
because i'm inclined to say like these
girls are the only fans like to
you to them like your boyfriend is just
one million like there is no
romantic thing happening like it's
really akin to
watching watching porn but the messages
how would you
feel if your husband had an only fans
account with like
six girls that he was like messaging but
the messaging is just like part of the
no it's a description no it's not like
that's the thing i think the subscribing
to six
honestly they say like only fans is a
really really good alternative to free
porn you're paying the people
like creators 100 so i would actually
i say this now but like if i opened
ben's laptop and he was subscribed to
like supporting a couple
only fans as creators a couple creators
as opposed to watching free porn
i would think he was a great guy and the
messaging
is what i really don't like because you
pay for content and that's what the
service is on only fans
messaging is not included in that so
building a relationship that's really
where the betrayal is
yeah i agree and then also and then
then you said some other stuff that was
a red flag more so than the only fans
because i think
i think a lot of couples it's a gray
area it's a it's a hurdle that a lot of
a lot of couples are going to have he
controls what you wear and jealous of
your guy friends this guy sounds like
bad [ __ ] news especially
when he's philandering on his laptop all
that all the time yep
i really don't like this man my unbiased
opinion is like
each time like girl find someone where
you live you'll be so much happier not
being in a long distance
and find someone who respects you like
based on your the way that you frame
things like it sounds like this was a
high school relationship that now is a
college relationship because you said
university
and i do think that high school
relationships there's a time and a place
and it's in high school
and it's time to move on it's definitely
time you need to
you need to expand your rings if the two
of you are meant to be together you'll
get back together but like
fly yeah also i kind of feel like he's
kind of manipulative like when you
called him out on it
um he's just like trying to make it up
like he just
i don't know he's getting bad vibes yeah
i'm sure you actually tried to make him
sound good
yeah a hundred percent i think it's time
to let it go get on hit
hinge or whatever no just go to like
your campus
bulletin all right you're in college oh
no you don't even need a new boyfriend
like go live like you're in college
that's what i'm saying
you've been in a long distance
relationship like girl's got to get laid
like
it's time all right third and final one
hey claude and jax how you doing
good so i have a bit of a dilemma one of
my best friends is getting married next
year and when we were hanging out the
other day she told me she wants to be a
part of her wedding but just not as a
bridesmaid but still do everything with
them and wear the same color as them
which i was totally fine with until she
told me that she's having 10 bridesmaids
and i'm the only one out of the friends
that isn't in the wedding she tried
explaining herself but honestly she made
things worse as she would go on to say
i'm not as close
close with so and so but they would be
devastated if they weren't in my wedding
and i know that you would be more
understanding
honestly at this point i just don't want
to be a part of it especially not
wearing the same color as the bridesmaid
i feel like that's really odd
should i talk to her about it or just
stick it out and be the weird girl at
the wedding that's trying to be a
bridesmaid help a toaster who doesn't
want to be known as the wannabe
bridesmaid
this is [ __ ] i would say i'm just
like these these
quantities are bothering me today
everyone just is out here acting so
disrespectfully towards our precious
toasters i would say eat my ass
okay i'm not spending money on your
bachelorette party i'm not getting a
dress in the color that you want just so
i can be [ __ ] disrespected
one out of out of ten girls this is so
like this is a husband
thing to do like i think you say i'm not
interested i'm
happy to come to the wedding as a guest
but i'm not interested in this weird
alternative plan you have
to make me feel bad and to make your
losery friends feel good like i'm out of
here do not do this like that would make
you
the biggest [ __ ] doormat of all time
do not do this
stand up for yourself have some
self-respect do not do this don't do it
if you write us an update and you tell
us you did this like i'll be so
disappointed in you
don't do it like it's so [ __ ] rude
like it isn't
a thing where like you have your
bridesmaids and then you have people who
come on your backside who you're like
close with
and want to celebrate with but like
you're not that they're
they're not that close well you just
have
your your number is too big but it's
never just one person
and that those people don't wear the
color dress yeah
i guess like at my wedding i had a lot
of people come on my bachelorette party
just because like i wanted more of the
merrier
and they all came to the wedding they
didn't walk down the aisle they didn't
wear
the color i think that's fine no that's
what i did too
okay okay yeah i think that that's fine
i think that a bachelorette party like
is really fun the more the merrier and
truly
the more the merrier but to ask them to
wear a specific color dress and then
be the only one not walking down the
aisle
i would say go [ __ ] yourself i actually
like it this is so hurtful i wouldn't
even go to the wedding
no i would i would rip her a new one but
that's just like the mood i'm in right
now some girls just get so [ __ ]
wild when they're brides and then i'm
sure she'll show the text her friends be
like
could you believe she said this to me
like make sure i'm sweating
make sure to say it nice be like
honestly i really don't feel comfortable
with this i'm happy just to come as a
guest
so you don't make put it on her so you
don't have to make that hard decision so
you don't
and put something in about the other
friend so that if she shows it to the
other friends
she's getting herself a job yeah yeah
yeah yeah i know you'd want to let emily
cara and sarah
put them in my name so that when you so
that she can't screenshot it and send it
to other people without making yourself
look i know you said emily cara and
sarah shouldn't be bridesmaids but you
don't want to hurt their feelings
because they can't handle it because
they're weak women
unlike me so and then make it seem like
you're i'll take the burden off of you
like you're the hero here you're the
martyr and honestly like
not being in someone's bridal party is
such a gift like it's such torture to be
a bridesmaid i wouldn't say i would
start out the text saying
no offense but that's horseshit
that's how i would start it and then
list your reasons and make sure to
reference
emily cara and sarah by name first and
last emily jones
so that she can't send it to the group
genius genius and that's our show that
was your toasters if you ever want to
write in that's dear toasters gmail.com
we'll always keep it anonymous we'll
change people's names don't worry we'll
protect your identity because we protect
the toasters
and if we've uh read one of your
quandaries on air recently and you have
an update for us also feel free to send
that to your toasters gmail.com
we love you guys very much we hope you
have an amazing home day and we'll see
you tomorrow for the last show of the
week
before the long weekend the 4th of july
oh my gosh we have to sell we have to do
something so special tomorrow maybe a
little
came in thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so it's spotify itunes
stitcher public radio i heart radio
video catchbox all the places so
wherever we listen to podcast five
nights and morning chelsea five star
review about our beautiful smart we are
hope you guys have an amazing day we'll
see you tomorrow for thursday goodbye
you